So let's plug in these smoothing
methods into the ranking function to
see what we will get.
So, this is a general smoothing...
sorry, general ranking function for
smoothing with collection language model.
You have seen this before.
And now we have a very specific
smoothing method, the JM smoothing
method.
So now let's see what what's the value
for alpha sub D here.
And, what's the value for P sub seen
here?
So we may need to decide this in order
to figure out the exact form of the
ranking function, and we also need to
figure out, of course, Alpha.
So let's see, well, this ratio.
Is basically this right? So
Here this is the probability of seeing
word on the top.
And this is the probability of unseen
word, or in other words, lambda is basically the alpha here. So it's easy to see that this can be rewritten
as this.
Very simple. So we can plug this into
here.
And then here, what's the value for
alpha?
What do you think?
It will be just Lambda, right?
And, what would happen if we plug in
this value here?
If this is lambda, what can we say
about this?
Does it depend on the document?
No, so it can be ignored.
Right?
So we end up having this ranking
function shown here.
And in this case, you can easily see
this is precisely a vector space model,
because this part is the sum over all
the matched query terms.
This is the element of the query vector
what do you think is the element of the
document vector?
It's this, so that's our
document.
vector element.
And let's further examine what's inside
this logarithm.
So one plus this, so it's going to be
a non-negative
log of this.
It's going to be at least one, right?
And this is a parameter.
So Lambda is parameter and let's look
and this is a TF.
Now we see very clearly this TF
weighting here.
And.
The larger the count is, the higher the
weight will be.
We also see IDF weighting which is
given by this.
And with our document length normalization
here.
So all these heuristics are captured in
this formula.
What's interesting that we kind of have
got this weighting function
automatically by making various
assumptions, whereas in the vector
space model we had to go through those
heuristic design in order to get
this.
And in this case note that there is a
specific form and we can see whether
this form actually makes sense.
So what do you think
Is the denominator here?
This is the length of document, total
number of words multiplied by the
probability of the word given by the
collection.
So this actually can be interpreted as
expected count of the word.
If we're going to draw a word from the
collection language model and we want
to draw as many as the number of words
in the document.
If you do that, the expected count of
a word W would be precisely given by
this denominator.
So this ratio basically is comparing
the actual count here.
The actual count of the word in the
document with the expected count
given by this product.
If the word is in fact the following,
the distribution in the collection
this.
And if this counter is larger than the
expected count, this part, this
ratio would be larger than one.
So that's actually a very interesting
interpretation, right?
It's very natural.
And intuitively it makes a lot of
sense.
And this is one advantage of using this
kind of probabilistic reasoning.
Where we have made explicit
assumptions, and we know precisely why
we have a logarithm here and why we
have these probabilities here.
And we also have a formula that
intuitively makes a lot of sense.
And does TF-IDF weighting and document
length normalization.
Let's look at the Dirichlet Prior
Smoothing.
It's very similar to the
case of JM smoothing.
In this case, the smoothing parameter
is Mu and that's
different from lambda that we saw
before, but the format looks very
similar.
The form of the function looks very
So we still have linear interpolation
here.
And when we compute this ratio, while
we defined that is that the ratio is
equal to this.
But what's interesting here is that we
are doing another comparison here now.
We're comparing the actual count
with the expected count of the word
if we sample Mu words according to
the collection of the probability.
So note that it's interesting we don't
even see document length here.
Unlike in the JM smoothing.
So this of course should be plugged
into this part.
So you might wonder, where
is the document length? Interestingly,
the document length is here.
In alpha sub d so this would be
plugged into this part.
As a result, what we get is the
following function here, and this is
again a sum over all the matched query
words.
And we again see the query term
frequency here.
And you can interpret this as the
element of a document vector.
But this is no longer a simple dot
product, right?
Because we have this part.
And note that n is the length of the
query.
So that just means if we score this
function we have to take a sum over all
the query words and then do some
adjustment of the score based on the
document.
But it's still
It's still clear that it does document
length normalization because this lens
is in the denominator, so a longer
document will have a lower weight here.
And we can also see it has TF here and
then IDF. Only that this time the form
of the formula is different
from the previous one in JM
smoothing.
But intuitively, is still implements TF
IDF weighting and document length
normalization.
Again, the form of the function is
dictated by the probabilistic reasoning
and assumptions that we have made.
Now there are also
disadvantages of this approach, and
that is there's no guarantee that such
a form of the formula would actually
work well.
So if you look back at this retrieval
function. Although it's TF IDF
weighting and stopping the length normalization
, for example, it's unclear
whether we have sub-linear
transformation.
But Fortunately we can see here.
There is a logarithm function here, so
we do have also the here, right? So
we do have the sub-linear transformation,
but we did not intentionally do that.
That means there's no guarantee that
will end up in this in this way.
Suppose we don't have logarithm, then
there's no sub linear transformation.
As we discussed before, perhaps the
formula is not going to work so well. So that's
example of the gap between formal model
like this and the relevance that we have
to model, which is really a subjective
machine.
That is tight to users.
So it doesn't mean we cannot fix this.
For example, imagine if we did not have
this logarithm, right?
So we can heuristically add one, or we
can even add a double logarithm, but
then it would mean that the function is
no longer probabilistic model.
So the consequence of the modification
is no longer as predictable as what we
have been doing now.
So that's also why, for example, BM 25
remains very competitive and still open
challenge how to use probabilistic
model to derive a better model than
BM25.
In particular, how do we use query likelihood
to derive a model that would work
consistently better than BM25?
Currently we still cannot do that.
It's still an interesting open question.
So to summarize this part we've talked
about the two smoothing methods.
Jelinek-Mercer, which is doing fixed
coefficient linear interpolation.
Dirichlet Prior, this is to add
pseudocounts to every word and is doing
adaptive interpolation in that the
coefficient would be larger for shorter
documents.
In both cases we can see by using these
smoothing methods we would be able to
reach a retrieval function,
whether assumptions are clearly
articulated, so they're less heuristic.
Experiment results also show that these
retrieval functions also are very
effective, and they are comparable to
BM 25 or pivoted length normalization.
So this is a major advantage of
probabilistic model where we don't have
to do a lot of heuristic design. Yet
in the end, we naturally implemented TF
IDF weighting and document length
normalization.
Each of these functions also has
precisely one smoothing parameter.
In this case, of course, we still need
to set the smoothing parameter, but
there are also methods that can be used
to estimate these parameters.
So overall this shows by using
probabilistic model we follow very
different strategy than the vector
space model.
Yet in the end we end up with some
retrieval functions that look very
similar to a vector space model with
some advantages in having assumptions
clearly stated.
And then the form dictated by
probabilistic model.
Now, this also concludes our discussion
of the query likelihood problems model. And
let's recall what assumptions we have
made in order to derive the functions
that we have seen in this lecture.
We basically have made four assumptions
that I listed here.
The first assumption is that the
relevance can be modeled by the query
likelihood and the second assumption
we've made.
It is a query words are generated
independently that allows us to
decompose the probability of the whole
query.
Into a product of probabilities of all
the words in the query.
And then the third assumption that we
have made is if a word is not seen in the
document that we're going to let its
probability with proportional to
its probability in the collection of
the smoothing with the collection language
model, and finally we've made
one of these two assumptions about the
smoothing.
So we either use JM smoothing or the
Dirichlet smoothing.
If we make these four assumptions, then
we have no choice but to take the form
of the retrieval function that we have
seen earlier.
Fortunately, the function has a nice
property in that implements TF IDF
weighting and documents length normalization
And,
these functions also work very well, so
in that sense these functions are less
heuristic compared with a vector space
model.
And there are many extensions.
This basic model and you can find the
discussion of them in the reference at
the end of this Lecture.